quand avez vous senti cette boule et à
deux mois environ
est-ce que je ne m'inquiétais c'est un
stade 3
est ce que vous êtes malade j'ai un
cancer du sein vous savez que dans cette
épreuve il faudra vous montrer plus fort
que vous ne l'êtes
on va pas verser de larmes je te demande
seulement de mederi très forte
des voeux s'est réalisé mais quelle
c'est une fille c'est beau cadeau pour
tani pour toi ô va
ça
ce lien
mon voeu est que tu n'aies son bonne
santé
j'ai un autre veut c'est plus fort que
moi j'aimerais que plus tu grandis mois
plus tôt
je t'aime c'est pour cette raison nous
reste en vie forte
c'était
tu sais quel est le plus bel amour qui
existe au moins celui d'une mère pour
son fils et celui qu'un fils à sa mère
c'est pas ça chez moi
la ligne à
ça
sonia
il soigne on est
de montagne
m
bravo c'est ça le dénommé je suis choqué
les relâchements